parte ven para hacer un menor que ten
menor que uno existe un punto en la
curva cuya recta tangente tiene una
pendiente que toma el valor de dos para
que tiempo t la partícula se encuentran
en ese punto bueno si la pendiente de la
recta tangente es de 2 aquí dicen toma
el valor de 2 eso quiere decir que
entonces la derivada de james esto con
respecto a x esto tiene que ser igual a
2 ahora no nos dicen directamente cuánto
es la derivada de con respecto a x pero
si nos dan estos dos este de aquí es la
derivada de x la derivada de x con
respecto al tiempo es decir la
componente x del vector velocidad es la
tasa de cambio de x con respecto al
y aquí tengo a la derivada de james con
respecto al tiempo la derivada de james
con respecto al tiempo es decir que la
componente ya del vector velocidad es la
tasa de cambio de james con respecto al
tiempo y podemos usar a estos dos para
averiguar la derivada de y con respecto
a x porque qué pasa si tomas la derivada
de james con respecto al tiempo ya esto
lo divides entre la derivada de x con
respecto al tiempo que pasa si te tomas
esto como una división bueno yo espero
que conceptualmente se entienda si ves
estas diferenciales de esta forma si las
ves como fracciones tradicionales bueno
los de test se van a cancelar y entonces
te quedarás con la derivada de james con
respecto a x no es así ahora si lo
quieres pensar de una manera más formal
puedes ir a la regla de la cadena
qué pasa si te tomas la derivada de
james
con respecto al tiempo bueno pues esto
es lo mismo que la derivada del yen con
respecto a x por la derivada de x con
respecto al tiempo estas dos expresiones
son exactamente lo mismo esto tal cual
viene de las reglas de la cadena déjame
ponerlo viene de la regla
de la cadena y bueno entonces si
dividimos ahora de ambos lados entre la
derivada de x con respecto a te observa
que vamos a llegar justo a lo mismo
vamos a llegar aquí a esta expresión
original y para qué nos sirve esto bueno
porque ya sabemos que la derivada del ye
con respecto a t la tenemos acá arriba
es la componente bien del vector
velocidad y es en elevado a la 0.50 bien
ya esto lo voy a dividir entre la
derivada de x con respecto a t que es la
componente x el vector velocidad y bueno
es coseno coseno de tm elevado al
cuadrado bien y esto va a ser igual a la
derivada de ya con respecto a x pero
nosotros queremos que esta derivada sea
igual a 2 entonces esto lo vamos a hacer
igualados ya
déjame bajar un poco esta pantalla para
poder terminar este inciso y ahora vamos
a simplificar un poco esta expresión
para que nos quede algo de la forma
efe de x igual a 0 bueno en este caso
será ft pero la calculadora resuelve
este tipo de ecuaciones así que para
hacer eso que te parece si multiplicamos
de ambos lados por el coseno de t
cuadrada y me va a quedar que es elevado
a la 0.5 t es igual a dos veces el
coseno de tm elevado al cuadrado bien y
quiero esto igual a cero así que voy a
pasar dos veces el coseno de cuadrada
del otro lado o dicho de otra manera
podemos restar dos veces el cociente
cuadrada de ambos lados y me va a quedar
que es elevado a la 0.5 t menos
dos veces el coseno dt elevado al
cuadrado esto va a ser igual a cero y
esta ecuación que tengo aquí ya podemos
meterla a la calculadora y así encontrar
una t aproximada que sea la solución
usando la función a solberg entonces
déjame traer por acá la calculadora la
tengo por acá y bueno vamos a hacer esta
ecuación igual a cero así que para eso
voy a irme a matt después a solver que
es el número cero le voy a dar enter y
me pide la ecuación cero igual y bueno
voy a escribir todo en términos de x
para que lo entienda la calculadora me
va a quedar la función
elevado a la 0.5 x ok
a esto le voy a quitar dos veces el
coseno de x elevado al cuadrado muy bien
y esto tiene que ser igual a cero así
que voy a presionar enter y me aparece
esta pantalla de aquí y esta pantalla de
aquí lo que me pide es que le dé un
valor aproximado para que busque a x
pero lo que me dice este problema es que
te está entre 0 y 1 así que voy a ocupar
esta información y voy a poner la
calculadora a buscar cerca del valor de
0.5 que busque cerca de este a ver si
encuentra una solución a esta ecuación
así que para eso voy a apretar alfa y
después sort y ahora se va a tardar un
poco y ya está
obtengo que te porque recuerda que t es
nuestra incógnita tenemos
aproximadamente tomar el valor de 0.84
a cero así que déjenme notarlo la
solución de esta ecuación que tengo aquí
es una t aproximada aproximada a 0.84 0
y ya está
con esta te de aquí hemos acabado el
problema